- [Gary] Do this
again for my vlog
'cause America will love it.
- You go by Nate or Nathan?
- No, Nathan.
- [Gary] I want you to
tell the vlog your name.
You go first.
- Nathan Scherotter.
- Nathan Schofler.
- [Gary] One more time.
- Nathan Scherotter.
- Nathan Schofler.
- [Gary] One more time.
("Monday To Monday" by Saba)
Saba, I've been telling you.
("Sound Of The Gun" by Gallo)
This is nice and cozy.
The private plane is
gonna seduce me eventually.
I don't want to succumb.
I don't want to.
In Missouri,
going to the Cowboys,
Jerry Jones,
leadership off-site.
Should make a lot of you happy,
a lot of you mad.
Polarizing team.
I like him 'cause we
both hate the Giants.
Awesome, my friend.
("Sound Of The Gun" by Gallo)
Good, how are you?
Delaney Folley's around.
- [Man] Yeah, she
is at the big house.
If you just follow
this road on down,
you'll see the big house.
- [Gary] Thank you very much.
Got to go down to the big house.
Oh, that.
That makes a lot more sense.
Do more of like
vlog style today.
- [DRock] Okay.
- Do you know what I mean?
- [DRock] Yeah.
- More than like a
business video. You know?
- [DRock] Yeah.
- I mean obviously
we have to keep that.
- [DRock] Yeah, yeah.
- [Man 2] So have
you had a crazy week?
Have you've been
all over the place?
- Where were we Monday?
- [DRock] We were in L.A.
- Oh right, yeah.
So, I was in L.A.
Had to do a red
eye which sucked.
It's been good, just busy.
- Yeah.
- You know? I think
only two or three weeks
a year do I get all
five days in New York.
- Right.
- So, it's pretty normal.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Hell yeah.
Sure, I'm a big fan of that.
But you said a
very important part.
You said a five minute meeting.
(group laughter)
And it sounded like it
was something important
because what I'm not
scare of that, I love that.
What I'm scared of is the
millions of one hour meetings
that could've been 17 minutes
that weren't
actually that important.
And they creep up.
And we're in
client services, right?
That's what we do for a living.
So that's all we
do for a living.
We don't go
practice on the field,
we don't go play.
That's what we do.
We have meetings, we strategize
and then we produce stuff
to make something happen.
And so the amount of
ego on the creative side.
I mean, how many times opinion,
that wasn't blue enough.
The star's not big enough.
Right?
(group laughter)
- [Man 3] That
was good right there.
- It's unbelievable how I,
I only like this.
You know, this is the best.
So, this is all I do. I do five
minute meetings with everybody
that works for me.
Duh-duh-duh-duh.
But when I think about somebody
I use technology as
the gateway drug to enable
the face to face to
be far more powerful.
If you literally are
just leaving the ranch,
you got to fly back,
you're prepping for draft.
You might think about something
about one of your guys,
if you lived the way I lived
you'd go into
Instagram DM them and say,
"Hey Rick, I'm
thinking about you.
"I'm excited about,
Week 13 last week,
"you caught my
eye on something."
That changes, that
means the world to him
in his environment and then
when you sit down with him
the first day of camp,
you're already on
third and a half base, my man.
You're defining your
personal point of view on how
communication should
be done, in my opinion.
Right? Go read the
articles about why the
television was gonna be
destroying our society.
Why the telephone was
gonna destroy our society
'cause we were
gonna stop writing notes.
Your grandpappy's not thrilled
with the way
that you interacted.
You should've went
over to the guy next door
and shake his hand and
talk to him, not call him.
We've always judged the
next generation's version
of how they communicate.
They're communicating more.
People think their
kids are less social,
they're more social.
Every indicator shows that.
What happened if you
were in a school that
you go bullied and
it wasn't nice and
you had no friends but
now you can go on Twitch
and play video games with the
people that have your interest.
You have an outlet. Can't
take the good with the bad.
And that's only, don't forget,
you're the judge and
the jury of that opinion.
I can tell you
'cause I'm spending
a lot of time with these kids,
they're closer to each
other 'cause of these things
because during the off-season
when they're in
different places.
I just unbelievably am
non-romantic about how
you and I grow up in
locker rooms versus how they do
because I'm just a
big believer that humans
are the greatest
animal of all time and
we adjust to our realities
and yeah, I just don't see it.
I think we're not
leveling it up enough
when we have this conversation
and, by the way, I'm a big shot
because I'm looking at big data.
I'm only sitting here
peacocking 'cause I'm seeing
the actual manifestation
in a lot of places.
Efficiencies in warehouses,
I think you get a good vibe,
I run my business
like being a coach,
I love this stuff.
So, yeah, I think look,
I get it. Especially when
you actually played and
you lived that version of it.
I'm empathetic to that.
I just think that, I think we'll
be pleasantly surprised.
- [DRock] What was a fun
takeaway from that whole thing?
For the vlog?
- You know, I think the...
First of all, it was
clearly a strong organization.
Makes sense.
Jerry's one of the strongest,
most powerful owners
and super successful in business
and all that good jazz and
so that didn't surprise me.
It's what I expected.
Good people.
What I expected.
Only one fun takeaway,
it'll be fun to
play that, you know?
In the owner's
meeting in 30 years.
That's real cool, huh?
("Sound Of The Gun" by Gallo
Bye bye.
Bye bye, take
care of yourself.
- [DRock] Thank you.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- Safe journey.
- How are you?
- [Gary] Alright, good.
Hello.
DRock, why are
you so fancy now?
- I'm not.
- [Gary] Flying private,
got some cool Nikes.
People make art for you.
You got super fancy.
You sold out bro.
- You're right, I did sell out.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- [DRock] Gary,
why are you so fancy?
- 'Cause I'm fancy, that's why.
(DRock laughs)
You can only hold off
the inevitable for so long.
- [DRock] I mean
you're gonna make it
all meeting the
entire time, you know that?
- No, listen, I mean,
I'm not unaware
so many of you are like Gary,
why don't you go private more,
it saves time, I get it.
I get it, you know,
and especially when you go
to places like this.
Like if I'm going
to L.A., like, whatever.
But, like, when you're
going Springfield, Missouri
and you might
have to connect, or.
You have to make it
as efficient as possible.
Yeah, one brick at a time.
Not gonna own the New York Jets
and not have a private jet.
(DRock laughs)
I'm gonna drive to
the Cincinnati game.
- [DRock] Well, you know
like you said, you didn't
realize what comes along.
- Did not realize, yeah.
I still think that, for being
so smart, the fact that
I went from point A of
being a kid, a 20-year-old kid,
to owning the Jets, but
didn't realize private jets
and court side Knicks seats
were gonna happen in-between
that was a little naive.
Well, there's no
wifi, which sucks, so.
This is the
funniest part about me.
I use paper for my
fantasy baseball league.
Which everybody
makes fun of me for.
Which I make fun of myself for,
but I have a very hardcore,
like, system of how
I draft and it's an auction.
And we did a DailyVee
last year in auction,
but we didn't explain it.
It was early,
people hated the episode.
I loved it, can't
wait to look back at it.
But we're really gonna bring
it this weekend for you guys.
It's gonna be an epic episode.
And some of the things that
happened here will manifest
themselves on
Sunday and I'm prepared
to win the whole league.
That's the best part.
- [DRock] Do you
consider yourself
romantic on using paper?
- No, I think
that's a good question.
It's not that I'm
romantic about it.
It's that speed is what
I value over everything.
You think I want to
stand here in a vlog
and be like, I use paper.
I care about speed even over
my own reputation and brand.
I'm faster than
typing and going to
I don't use Excel, Google Docs.
That's not how I roll.
So all those spread sheets that
you'll see everybody working
with going back and forth.
I think I'm going to
process faster
in this maneuver.
Like, I know how I want it
organized to make the decisions
because once you go
into auction, you know,
I don't need a shortstop,
I have Correra locked in.
But I'm gonna need
a middle infielder.
And, like, I know how to
visually make this for myself.
And I don't know, I've just
never been somebody who natively
worked well in Excel sheets.
I'm ready.
("Next Move" by Rowlan)
Biggest thing for me it's just
like the stuff
I talk about business.
As I collect the data,
it's more about fixing
the well, not the sink.
I'm thinking about
my overall strategy,
factoring in what Staats
and Zhang, Bobby
Glennen are gonna do.
And those are the
people that have a chance,
choice a little bit.
And then factoring in
what people don't have a chance
are gonna do to set
themselves up for 2018.
AJ, Brandon, Little Lou,
the four headed monster of Nate,
Tyler, Anthony Latino,
and CFO, Alan,
DeRosa's gonna do dumb shit.
Marcus is in the
Office of the CEO.
He's one of the
smartest guys I know and
I disrespect him tremendously
in fantasy baseball.
It's as if his brain works for
everything that's important
and not for those
things that are not important.
It's going to be
an awesome weekend.
You like that?
I hope everybody's
killing their Thursday
DRock and I just
went to Missouri and back.
Only 4:20 in New York, we've
already been to Missouri, DRock.
("Next Move" by Rowlan)
Alright, what's up Facebook?
As you guys know I don't use
my normal Facebook account
because I use my fan page page.
But, what's up, actually,
I'd love to get some feedback.
I'm curious, who
actually sees this?
Leave a comment
please, I need to know.
I'm not even sure
who's seeing this.
My god, I'm seeing him
tonight for the wine event.
- [DRock] Really?
- Yeah. Nine years ago,
today, can you believe that?
- [DRock] No who is it?
Guy from Comcast.
How nuts is that?
- [DRock] That's awesome.
I haven't seen him
in like a long time.
God, I'm really
glad I did this studying.
I gotta admit, I didn't
know a lot of people.
There's a lot, I'm like,
who, who, who, who?
You know what's funny to read,
I've never read it before,
just never have the time, the
recap of the fantasy baseball
USA Today's leagues,
like who won and what?
Their traffic's really funny.
Now, but wait a minute, you're
scheduled seven to eight.
For the one hour interview
at DRock Saturday night.
Come with me.
Now I'm just
doing shit on the spot
because it can be like four
months later and be like, right?
I've been doing that a lot more.
Can we find a 45 minute or
hour window either next week
or early next week
to jam with the (inaudible).
- [Man] Thanks man,
appreciate it.
- What are you 22, 23?
- [Man] 29, I'm making
us a little bit older.
- [Man 2] His beard is 22.
- Yeah that, his beard is 18.
- [Gary] This is
literally why our company
is going to go out of business.
You know I'm
pissed about meetings,
and every time
I go into a meeting,
the first 17 minutes
is this horse shit.
(group laughter)
- We just started.
- It's 5:34.
- [Gary] Right 4 minutes
in already, horse shit.
Colin, sorry about the other
day. I'll see you next week.
- Okay.
- [Gary] Zhang!
The wifi was broken
on his private plane,
but I brought
paper just in case.
I did some real studying.
- [David] Paper research, wow.
- [Gary] I mean
I have all the data.
- [David] This year you
have to do a lot more work
'cause you have so many
minor league draft picks
that are gonna
follow up the next year.
That was the one
thing I was curious about
'cause you never really
do the minor league draft.
- [Gary] Yeah, you're right.
Yes, I'm doing homework there.
I have five
picks now, not seven.
But, no, but,
no I have to really win.
This is my year.
(group laughter)
No, no, this is my...
(indistinct chatter)
I've given up, to his point,
I've given up two full
years to try to win this year.
Two years ago, two years ago,
I said I was going to
rebuild for two straight years
because it's so competitive
and it's 20 teams
that you kind of have to
I almost think. You have to make
three year commitments.
You're playing
it real interesting.
Your's is really interesting.
- [David] I'm playing
for next year.
- [Gary] Are you?
- [David] Yeah.
- [Gary] That makes
me upset actually.
(group laughter)
Is that true?
- [David] Yeah.
- [Gary] Fuck, that's not good.
Is that true?
- [David] Yeah.
- [Gary] Well, he
has eight draft picks.
And your five keepers were,
you know what's funny?
Honestly, I'm upset
because I thought you
were playing for this year and
didn't feel
great about your five.
Now, they could
all work out great,
but I didn't
feel great about them.
- [David] I'm
playing for next year.
Wait until my
minor league draft.
My minor league
board is so set right now.
That's the only
thing I could study for.
- [Gary] So you're like really
got young kids on there.
Like the best 17-year-old.
- [David] Yeah.
- [Gary] Or whatever, right?
- [David] Yeah, exactly.
- [Gary] Fuck.
You're not
playing for this year.
- I play for every year.
- [Gary] But that's
why you never win.
- [Marc] And you have?
- Melis, can you tell your boss
that he should not go
for it in fantasy this year
and he should try to
build for the future?
- [Marc] You're just lucky I
know there is fantasy this year.
- [Melissa] Why are
you trying to go for it?
- [Marc] Thank you, good job.
Give her a raise.
- [Gary] A raise, promotion.
You now work for her, Marc.
- [Melissa] Can I get an office?
- [Gary] Yep!
Let's interrupt
this scene for a second.
You're gonna
show me in my office,
hopefully that's there.
- [DRock] Yeah,
yeah that is there.
- [Gary] You're
gonna go back to it.
You're gonna circle it.
You're going to
back to me saying,
Tyler, say you're sorry.
Hey Tyler, say you
sorry to thrift shop hustler.
- Hey Evilos, I'm so terribly
sorry I forgot to tag you
on the last episode.
We got to put
these things out quick
and sometimes
things just slip through.
I hope you're doing really well.
Amazing work, I won't
slip up next time. Peace.
And then we'll move on.
- [DRock] I love it.
("Next Move" by Rowlan)
- [Gary] Hey, what's going on?
What are you working on?
- [Iris] Your announcement.
- [Gary] Ah.
- [Iris] I'm really excited.
- [Gary] It's good, right?
- [Iris] Yeah.
- Yeah, it's gonna
have to be hardcore.
Nice pants.
Marcus, how's your
studying been going?
- [Marcus] It was really
good like three weeks ago,
right after surgery
and now it's in shambles.
- [Gary] Perfect.
(DRock laughs)
I've been sending
Marcus extra work.
I'm joking but we
have our fantasy draft.
The other night I
was like, you know what?
I bet you he's studying.
Marcus, immediately first
thing tomorrow morning,
I need this 400 page deck.
Claude is the only person who's
ever had a full
DailyVee about her
and look at her pants.
Show the pants.
- [DRock] I know,
they're rad pants.
Alan, have you been
studying for the fantasy draft?
- [Alan] Don't
need to, my friend.
(Claude laughs)
- You ever hear
walking into a buzzsaw?
(DRock laughs)
That's what Alan's about,
I can't wait for his face.
- I really put in some time.
- [Gary] You have?
(group laughter)
Alright, let's do this.
Sorry Matt, Juliet,
I'm just getting very excited
for the draft on Sunday.
Let's do this.
("Next Move" by Rowlan)
Yeah, I felt like you forced it.
It wasn't there
the first year or two,
and I feel like
you forced it on this,
I'm not a pure New Yorker, just
want to remind everybody
I'm from a
different place slightly.
- [Nate] Don't say
y'all in Arizona either.
- [Gary] Well then
it's very fake.
- [Nate] It's 'cause my
parents are from Texas.
My family's from Texas.
- [Gary] Here's the bottom line,
you know what's
funny about his laugh?
That was the first time he
actually bought into my thesis.
(Gary laughs)
That's what that was.
- [Marcus] (inaudible)
but the emotion
behind it was interesting.
- [Gary] It was absolutely not
there for two years, three years
in New York and
then out of nowhere
you threw it in, somewhere
around the time
Mickey was about to...
Yeah, yeah. That's right.
You just really
aren't a good guy.
It's as simple as that.
He never said it once for the
first three years
he was around me.
- [Nate] I don't think you can
say that with 100% confidence.
- [Gary] You know what's funny,
I know you very well.
You know I'm right.
- [Nate] I don't think you,
I've for sure said "y'all."
- [Gary] Somewhere
around the time Mickey was
heading to Chatt,
just so you know,
somewhere around the
time that Mickey was starting
to make his transition and he
started saying it more often
'cause he was trying
to get back into practice,
Nate slipped one in and
tried to see what happened.
And I didn't call him out on it
'cause I remember thinking
he was maybe making a joke
'cause we could've stopped it
right then and there but nope.
- [Claude] But nope.
- [Gary] By the way, he's
still not consistent with it.
- [Nate] By the way, "y'all" is
much better than "you guys."
- [Marcus] Y'ins. Do that.
- [Gary] I say "y'all."
(group laughter)
So much talent at Vayner.
Vinny's singing?
Corey what to you think?
- It's cool.
- [Gary] So was
that thumbs up, bro.
That was awesome. (laughs)
(DRock laughs)
- [David A] You like art?
- I love art.
When it's in sneaker form.
- Hey, I'm glad you could come.
- [Gary] I'm glad I made it.
- One of those
is actually for you.
She gonna surprise it to you.
- [Gary] Why'd
you ruin her surprise?
- I know.
- [Gary] What a bad guy!
- Sorry!
- [Gary] What a bad guy.
How are you? Hi.
Hey, hey, how are you?
How are you?
Yeah, I feel like if you
look deep into the blue...
Look at Lock, that's really good.
Do this again for my vlog
'cause America will love it.
- You go by Nate or Nathan?
- No, Nathan.
- [Gary] I want you to
tell the vlog your name.
You go first.
- Nathan Scherotter.
- Nathan Schoeffler.
- [Gary] One more time.
- Nathan Scherotter.
- Nathan Schoeffler.
- [Gary] One more time.
(group laughter)
Please just one more time.
- Nathan Scherotter.
- Nathan Schoeffler.
- [Gary] Okay, and now
for my Instagram story.
Hey guys, what's your name?
- Nathan Schoeffler.
- Nathan Scherotter.
- Schoeffler.
- Scherotter.
- [Gary] Thank you.
(DRock laughs)
Let's go.
Hey.
I love this.
How about
getting the whole scene?
Yeah, Vin!
- Oh, hey Gary.
- [Gary] Hey Vin.
- Thank you for coming.
- [Gary] Good.
- [Vinny] Good to see ya.
- Great to see you, Vin.
- [Tyler] Do we want--
- [Gary] Just get as much in
the background as possible.
Thanks guys.
- Thank you.
- [Gary] Or Bone
Thugs 'N Harmony.
Should give back to the
company a little bit, don't I?
It's given you so much.
So here's...
Oh so that's huge, great, so
here's what I would go with.
I would go with, the
current state of CMOs are
architects but
not practitioners,
I was groomed at
a place like that.
I know you guys have
some context for that,
but let me tell you the things
that I would have needed.
I think you really
have to play to, you know,
I know that you guys haven't
worked with Vayner or Gary,
the one thing
that he's good at is,
even though he's in outer
space, all the way up there,
he still knows, he knows,
he knows the little details
of hashtags and this and that,
and that's the future of CMOs
and that's how I'm being built.
To be able to do
a Super Bowl spot,
or a single post
on musical.ly that are
both effective
for the dollar amount.
Heading to a dinner
that I put together.
Random wine dinner with some
clients and friends and leaders
and so, should be a lot of fun.
Looking to do more of that to,
as my world gets bigger.
Instead of being
one of the guests,
maybe being the
host of these dinners
and helping people
collide into each other
and maybe do some stuff,
so should be fun.
Looking forward
to that, gonna be
there in a minute.
Got back from Missouri,
fun day, it's like
it's almost like
living three lives, right?
Like, you know,
seems like yesterday
that I was in front of
the Cowboys' leadership.
Got back, worked
on some re-org stuff,
got a lot going on at Vayner,
bunch of stuff
going on at Vayner.
Just offense, offense, offense,
just never settle,
never settle, never settle.
Enjoying that.
That was the majority of that.
Anything else I did there?
- [DRock] Art show.
Oh, I stopped by the art show.
It was great to see
Vayner culture doing it's thing,
just love them
loving each other.
That's probably the
best thing I can say,
and then just
having a conversation with
somebody and just talking about
architect and
plumbing, you know.
Literally what I said,
it's real, like, right?
Like, are you
capable of planning
the media and
distribution of the Super Bowl
and the support
around it, campaign?
That's a $20 million campaign,
and are you capable to
post something on musical.ly
with a picture that
might cost $700
and understand
every little nuance
that you can put
in there, much like
The #AskGaryVee Show
that you just saw
about the nuances of
titles and thumbnails,
or all the things that
we do on a daily basis.
I really genuinely believe that,
that's why I use the
architect and the mason, right?
Person designs a home,
but can he actually,
you know, put the brick and
the cement on it and place it?
Like, are you that good?
Are you
strategic and executional?
Can you go way up in the
clouds and be in the dirt?
It is a life philosophy,
it is definitely a
marketing execution philosophy,
it is why I'm winning.
It's, you know,
it's ego, it's humility, right?
It's micro-fast, it's macro-slow.
It's Super Bowl, it's a
single post on Instagram.
Pulling from
opposite directions.
That's where the magic is.
- [DRock] Clouds and dirt.
- Clouds and dirt mother fucker.
[Gary Voiceover] I full
believe, I am bought in
that there's an ROI here.
I don't need the reports.
I don't need Nielson's,
I don't need seven years later.
If you need the
life where you were
gonna do something
nice for somebody
just based on
what they were gonna
do nice for you
in return right then,
that wouldn't be a cool world.
But the truth is
the best relationships
are the ones where
you give them something
and then you start
forming a relationship
that then may
benefit you somewhere
along the line in the future.
Got it?
Awesome sauce!
Adam Howser,
one of the best
operators in the business.
- [Man 2] Howser's in the
kitchen fuckin' makin' it.
That was made by Adam.
You look buff.
- Not bad, right?
- Dude, I have
something crazy to show you.
- Yeah, what you got?
- This literally pops up
in my Facebook today.
- Aaah!
Dude.
- [Gary] Nine years ago today.
(group laughter)
How sick is that?
- It was meant to be.
- [DRock] Is that
the craziest thing?
- That's meant to be.
Oh, that's awesome.
I was lookin' for
my wristband, man.
- Kim, why don't
you start us off.
- Sure.
- Who you are and
a little, a fun fact.
A New York Jets fact please.
- No.
I have zero.
- [Gary] I know.
She's a Bills fan.
- Bills beat the Jets
and knocked them out of
the Playoffs.
- Two years ago.
That's a long time ago.
- Stories, like I--
- [Gary] Your daughter's
the coolest person I know,
and I haven't met her yet.
But just from your stories.
- It's true, it is true.
- [Gary] Including,
I was at a meeting
with Sue the
other day on a call,
I was talking
about an up and coming
hip hop artist named Logic, and,
I said it so fast,
but this is how Sue rolls.
Literally, by the
time I hung up the phone,
I had a text back
from her, which was
a screenshot of a
text that she sent
to her daughter
during the call, she's like,
"Do you know who Logic is?"
And she was like,
"Mom! He's the best,
"that's why I'm going to
like Jingleball or whatever."
- Gov Ball.
- Gov Ball, right.
- Oh my god!
- How old is she?
- Seventeen.
- Lifelong Jets fan.
- [Gary] Guys, I
have a real fun fact.
This is straight truth.
VaynerMedia exists
because of this guy,
and I'm not kidding.
This is real.
I forgot it actually,
and when I saw him at South-By,
we were having a meeting and I,
it triggered
and I told it to the
eight or nine people there.
When I was in a transition and
started really realizing
the world was moving
and AJ was four or five
months away from graduating
college, we were still
debating what we were gonna do.
And the finalists were,
actually this guy probably
fucked me up a little bit,
let me explain why.
The finalists were,
the finalists were
a site that basically
would've probably been
Groupon or Living
Social, very similar,
or we were gonna go
very hard into fantasy sports
and build out the
fantasy sports world.
And this is, you know,
ten years ago, right?
But, I got an email
from him and his crew
at ABC ESPN Disney,
like, where were you?
What was it?
- Disney.
It was Disney.
- [Adam] Yeah, it was Disney.
And we, they said come in,
and do like a day or a
couple hours or consulting.
And this is when I first started
getting paid for speaking.
And I was like, wait a minute,
I should charge for this.
And they were like,
"How much do you want?"
And I was like,
"$5,000 the hour!"
And they were like,
"Okay, great, send the invoice."
- [Adam] I think Bernie laughed.
- Yeah.
- [Adam] Bernie first laughed.
- Laughed, yeah,
that's exactly right.
So I came, I came in, we hung,
Bernie who I
still talk to, Rohan,
like, great crew
of guys and gals.
I left, I go downstairs,
I call AJ.
This is just straight
up what happened, I go,
"Hey, maybe we should
start a consulting agency firm."
That's literally what happened.
It's crazy.
("Demons" by Rowlan)
- We're on this big
ship and we're gonna turn,
we'll have partners that'll
turn us in the right direction.
My analogy has
completely shifted.
Now it's like,
we built this field,
we built this game,
let's call it football.
- [Gary] I like football.
- We have our uniforms,
we have our outfits,
we have really cute outfits.
We have a ball, they
came up with the rules,
we have the
Super Bowl like every year.
One day we wake up
and we get to the field
and it's a whole new
thing, it's basketball.
And we, our
quarterbacks can't dunk.
So that rate of change, that's
a very different scenario
than just the evolution,
of turning the ship.
- [Gary] And
I will say something,
who's lucky enough to
play in different fields.
What's happening on the
consumer products level has a
- [Man 3] CT is different.
- Very different.
- Their technology--
- [Gary] And you guys
have done some very smart stuff
that has put you in
a very good position.
This world, you have
channel conflict coming,
DTCs coming, last mile's getting
very close to getting solved,
brands are getting commoditized.
Let's remember one
thing that is amazing.
What I am completely
blown away by,
actually I'd love
to ask this question.
I am stunned how few
people actually run a business.
One of the things that's
really running through my mind
as I'm starting to
really play with tycoon, yeah.
- [Man 3] We were
just talking about that.
- Is that right?
Like I'm getting goosebumps
'cause when I say to myself,
how many people
are actually running
(censored)?
Like you can start
getting into like, seven.
Like, you can start,
and so what happens is,
I have this
huge analogy of like,
companies are
based on the players.
The Lakers are really good when
Magic and Shaq are playing.
And they're really
bad when they're not.
And so for me, one of the things
that I'm really
fascinated by is,
these two I have a
ton of confidence in
because I know
the persons or person
that is actually running shit.
And I think
everything stems from that,
and it all trickles down,
and that's just
the straight truth.
("Demons" by Rowlan)